so jetzt höhere frauke petry hier als
nächste rednerin die ja als
fraktionslose abgeordnete hier im
bundestag sitzt sehr geehrte präsidentin
serie damen und herren in einem sind wir
uns in diesem haus vielleicht sogar
einig die causa kemmerich und die
reaktionen darauf haben ein politisches
erdbeben in diesem land verursacht und
ein tatsächlich auf mehrer leihweise ein
desaster für dieses land
über die gründe könnten ge freilich
nicht und einiger sein liebe linke sie
instrumentalisieren eine debatte über
die wahl eines fdp-abgeordneten
kemmerich und verstecken nicht einmal
dass es ihnen im kern gar nicht um die
verhinderung national sozialistischer
umtriebe geht sondern um die abschaffung
von wettbewerb geheim seien und die
beerdigung eines demokratischen
selbstverständnisses ausgrenzende ist
ihre strategie
sie hassen im kern die demokratische
kontroverse den ohne kontroverse das
kennen sie gut gibt es eine meinung wir
wissen alle wie wir fdp die cdu dass
dieses desaster eines mit ansage war es
wussten genug führungskräfte in beiden
parteien gescheitert
sie waren nur wieder einmal auf dem
medialen shitstorm von links und grünen
in keiner weise vorbereitet und so
dominieren wieder einmal die linken am
ende die offizielle politische lesart
das ist ein desaster par excellence
sie verschlafen 2015 eine antwort auf
die afd
ein strategiepapier denn seit 2015
können sie lesen dass genau das was und
jürgen passiert war
geplant war schon lange man müsste den
politischen gegner
wer endlich einmal ernst nehmen liebe
spd und grüne sie sind hier besonders
scheinheilige vertreter denn sie müssten
eigentlich kleinlaut zugeben dass sie im
vorfeld in thüringen einen bürgerlichen
ministerpräsidentin verhindert haben sie
haben sich einer wahl zum beispiel von
einem ohrring im vorfeld verweigert und
damit haben sie die zuspitzung auf genau
das was passiert ist nämlich eine
zuspitzung der ränder erst ermöglicht
alle diejenigen die ein
ich und reflexartig jetzt leichter von
weimarer verhältnissen reden machen
einen dramatischen fehler
sie stellen erste wahl sein kemmerich an
dem kandidaten der mitte mit der wahl
eines extremisten gleich schlimm
ich verstehe die angst aber die
gleichsetzung ist dennoch falsch
zweitens sie entwerten die lehre aus den
weimarer verhältnissen für den bürger
für die wähler den außerhalb der
politischen kreise versteht niemand was
sie sagen
ich rede nicht über die aktivisten auf
der straße die linksterroristen die
anschläge und so weiter das ist nicht
das normale volk in cdu und spd fdp
werden dazu noch rein weil sie
politische persönlichkeiten entsorgt
herr lindner fast andere gleich ganz und
sie helfen damit der afd
auch für mich unvorstellbare weise und
noch dramatischer ist das was folgt und
ich bitte sie dass ich wirklich zu
herzen zu nehmen
mit dem rückblick von den kemmerich
vereiteln sie am ende die möglichkeit
die möglichkeit das potenzial einer
bürgerlichen regierung und sie verhelfen
damit sie alle auch hier hans jörg
handreke an die fdp spitze vorzudringen
und jetzt glauben sie ja nicht dass das
gut wäre denn während die afg aktuell
führungslos ist und keine strategie hat
und stagniert obwohl sie massenweise
steilvorlagen jeder sei jetzt geboten
bekommen das und dann würden heute nicht
mehr passieren
seine berater haben eine strategie sie
haben eine vision und sie werden zwar
nicht demokratisch aber die afg am ende
einen und gott gnade diesem land was
dann passiert dann gehört gebiet
tatsächlich ein anderes deutschland
andere an der linken seite wollen das
auch aber sie immunisieren durch ihr
verhalten wirke für eine wählerschaft
die begriffe nazi und faschismus schon
lange nicht mehr ernst nehmen weil sie
über gebühr genutzt wurden das ist das
eigentliche drama in thüringen es ist
doch ihr werk und ich frage nicht
besorgt welche politische antwort sie
darauf in zukunft finden wollen
herzlichen dank